the pardons are starting in the latest
sign that no matter what donald trump
says publicly
he knows his days as president are
numbered and donald trump has pardoned
his former
national security adviser the convicted
michael
flynn now remember that michael flynn
pleaded guilty to lying to the fbi
about contact with russian officials
trump announcing the pardon of course
via twitter just hours before
thanksgiving saying quote it is my great
honor
to announce that general michael t flynn
has been granted a full pardon no
partial pardon for michael flynn a full
pardon
congratulations to general flynn and his
wonderful family
i know you will now have a truly
fantastic thanksgiving remember that
donald trump has already commuted the
sentence of his former campaign aide
roger stone
he's expected to pardon many more people
between now and january 20th and on the
table could be pardons for
paul manafort george papadopoulos
steve bannon has been charged but not
yet convicted
rudy giuliani is under federal
investigation for possibly breaking
lobbying laws there are many others now
on the one hand you would be absolutely
correct
to say these aren't just mere
presidential pardons
for crimes committed that have nothing
to do with the president himself
for better or worse these are
not traditional or standard pardons in
the sense that many of the people
that are potentially going to get
pardons and some who did get pardons
already
their crimes relate to donald trump's
own campaign or administration or
they relate to telling lies to help
donald trump so you are completely right
if your reaction is
this is not you know pardoning someone
who's been in prison for 20 years
for something you think is unfair these
are pardons related to crimes committed
as part of donald trump's campaign
transition team or administration
you would be completely right now at the
same time i'm seeing people
talking about oh trump needs to suffer
the consequences for doing this
he can't be allowed to get away with
pardoning these people who in many cases
committed crimes that were meant to help
hide the possible wrongdoing of donald
trump
my advice is don't even bother i like i
hate to be saying this
but we've got seven weeks left in this
administration
there is no chance that donald trump
will have any negative repercussions
from making these pardons
my recommendation is save your energy
and your focus and your sanity
and get to something else because it's
disgusting for me to be saying it
because it's the reality in the united
states but he
he's going to get get away with these
pardons as corrupt as they may be
now there is also the story here of
donald trump's hypocrisy
remember when donald trump explained
firing michael flynn he also did that
via twitter
where he said back in 2017 i had
to fire general flynn because he lied
to the vice president and the fbi he has
pled guilty to those lies it is a shame
because his actions during the
transition were lawful
there was nothing to hide trump isn't
pardoning flynn at least apparently
because he wasn't really guilty trump
concedes that flynn
did the thing he was convicted of trump
simply thinks it should be lawful
he's pardoning flynn for other reasons
presuming uh uh that he believes
flynn kept him out of trouble to some
degree
now if you really want to take a trip
down the delusional recesses of the
internet
there were pro-trump forums that when
donald trump pardoned michael flynn on
wednesday
they immediately started posting trump
pardoned flynn
because flynn is the last puzzle piece
in overturning the election results to
get donald trump a second term
just unbelievable delusions taking place
and think now of the full michael flynn
story as we understand it
during the transition barack obama told
donald trump i would not hire
michael flynn he's a national security
risk trump says i'm going to hire him
anyway
and makes him national security advisor
flynn
lies to the fbi was an unregistered
foreign agent
lied about his contacts with russia etc
trump fires him and concedes
flynn flynn lied yeah he he did it he's
guilty
flynn then helps robert mueller in his
investigation
which leads to robert mueller
recommending no jail time for flynn
flynn then recants the testimony on
which the no jail time recommendation
was made
and in comes donald trump and pardons
michael flynn
it it would be almost unbelievable
as a screenplay for a movie about
washington dc corruption but it's real i
i mean is is flynn the luckiest guy in
the world or is there a different way
that we should be thinking about it
absolutely unbelievable the the pardons
will be coming
and i am as uh curious as
you uh about who will be on that list
you may not have known this but when you
see me sitting here on the show
i am often wearing shirts by a company
called teddy stratford i asked them to
be a sponsor because they are by far
my favorite shirts that i own with
almost
all other slim fit button up shirts i've
worn
you get this annoying stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are which
does not look good
but what makes teddy stratford shirts
unique is this patented zipper that's
hidden underneath the buttons which
actually prevents the chest from looking
weird and stretched out like that
it looks really good and just all around
they cut the entire shirt in a specific
way
that makes your upper body look a lot
better it's just a much nicer and more
stylish fit
than you get from other shirts and they
hand make everything with 100
egyptian cotton and flat felled seams
which means it's going to be a lot more
durable
than other shirts and last a lot longer
which i really love
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman
at checkout